(audience clapping)
Hi, gorgeous lady.
Oh my gosh, you look amazing.
Right back at you, it's been too long, Drew, it's so,
first of all, before we get going,
I want to congratulate you on everything
and what a great, great show you're doing,
I'm just loving every minute of it,
and you never cease to amaze me.
Good for you, girl.
Thank you and I've wanted to collaborate with you
for as long as I can remember.
I've been such a fan of yours for so long,
and I think your body of work is just so extraordinary.
And you know, whether it's
when we were falling in love with you from
"Zorro" and "Entrapment",
you know all the way to your Academy Award,
which by the way I had a curious question,
that some of the producers
didn't necessarily want the bob for "Chicago", Is that true?
Yeah, it's true.
And so for me, when I saw Velma Kelly
I saw that blunt Louise Brooks look.
And also it's period.
You know, as an actor, you know the period,
they didn't have beach waves, you know, in 1930s, Chicago.
And I won that battle, you know, as you get older,
it's like one of the things I say to my daughter
because you can never put an old head on young shoulders
is like, pick your battles, you know,
just pick your battles,
sometimes you gotta let things go.
Other times you got to stand by your guns and just go,
no this is important.
And I did,
anyway, that kind of image
was always part of my vision for the character.
Well, and as you wield your Academy Award,
it's nice to know that those choices matter.
And you talked about your daughter and you know,
it's Mother's Day is around the corner
and I just was so excited,
your daughter's 18 now and about to go off to college right?
Yeah, no she is.
I mean.
I know, it's just it's always soaks up because
both Michael and I just about to become empty nesters.
Yes, exactly.
And that word for me, that term was like so cold.
It was like what do you mean empty nest?
They're not going anywhere,
they're just going off to school.
But the idea is, you know,
when I really sit down and think about it,
it gives me joy to be an empty nester.
Because I see what both Michael have done,
and look I'm not bragging, but you never know as a parent
what you're going to get, you know,
the best laid plans, whatever it's just,
two people come together and there's a creation,
and then you guide them
and I had a mother who,
you know, as you said Mother's Day is around the corner
who was a wonderful blueprint of what a mother should be,
you know, strict but gave good manners,
you know, for her it was manners.
A disciplinarian, but kind.
she gave us a long, long, long leash,
but we never ever made that taut or, you know,
try to get off the leash and do our own thing.
It was, this is where the leash is,
and you can go and have fun and do and explore and become
and, but you know, these are the parameters,
and with my children I try to instill those qualities,
the best I could
and both Michael and I, you know, when we,
the best best joy we have is when we get complimented
about our kids' behavior and their manners,
and how they're just good two grounded kids.
And so they've turned out great,
and so now that term empty nest,
I look at Michael and go, hey, remember me?
Now we go back to knowing we've done our bit
and we can enjoy their journey,
be there for them, for support.
Tell them if the leash is you know,
you need to rein it in a bit, but just be there
and let them enjoy this time.
They love, their lust for learning is just insatiable.
And so that gives me joy,
and their love of the craft of acting is so strong,
but even when Michael,
their brains, they want to,
they're doing politics and history in school,
but their passion is acting,
and they've never done anything professional,
but they would like to go into acting.
And, you know, you come from a family
where your name is synonymous.
Yes.
I think you feel a pull.
Yeah, and very much like Michael,
very similar stories where you both had to be
the kids of.
I never had that.
I was like, audition?
I'm in.
They don't want me?
I'll just queue up around the corner
and go back and stand in line again.
But my kids, Michael has said to them about,
what it's like to be the daughter of in the same industry,
which is, I guess, similar if you're in business.
You choose to settle in business, your kids have,
you know it's not an easy way in,
in fact one has to prove oneself more.
Yes, absolutely.
And so even with that deterrent, my kids are like,
nah, sorry we still want to do it.
So, and I've had a wonderful, wonderful life being an actor.
And if they get half the joy that I've had
all I want my kids to be is happy and healthy.
Everything else is a bonus, right?
Well, I love that you've let them be kids,
you let them figure out what they wanted for themselves
rather than telling them.
And I really respect the way that you
and your wonderful husband.
Gives you a big kiss by the way.
Oh my God, I love him so much, I can't even believe it.
And by the way, I heard that he notices
when you do something different
or you wear something different,
and he compliments you on it and you said smart guy.
And I thought, yeah, that is a smart guy.
Okay, but no, I'm not going to, no I'm not going to,
it's going to be, you know Michael can't do any wrong.
Nobody doesn't do, which happens.
Like I've never let him, it's happened,
I'd let it go.
But it happened a few times
is that he doesn't tell me
if I got something caught in my tooth.
Oh yeah, no, you have to do that,
that's like a girlfriend thing.
That's a girlfriend thing,
but if you're to a man for 20 years,
he's got to tell you that.
So now he's like,
now he says to me, come here, come here, come here.
I say, well, what, what, what, what
like a naughty school girl, what have I done?
What, what, what?
He goes, let me check your teeth.
Awww, you broke him for all the right reasons.
Men are like little puppies, you've got to train them.
I don't know what to say.
They are, they always could use a blueprint themselves.
Look, they're not born with crystal balls.
And you guys have been married for 20 years.
Yeah, 21 years in November.
20 years yeah.
And you have the same birthday.
We have the same birthday.
Yes, yes, yes.
I know it's bizarre.
And it's so funny because there's 20 years,
I mean, is there a reason why we're together?
There's so many things that connect us to this, connect us,
but like that's our wedding day, look at that.
It was one of the most amazing days of my life,
but yeah, 20, 20 years.
But even our handwriting is very similar.
You know, we can come from two different parts of the world
or two different types of families,
cultures and age 25 years difference,
but who's counting, I don't care.
I don't think age matters.
Numbers don't mean anything.
It's the soul and the heart and the life experience
and none of that has to do with numbers.
No, I'm with you on that.
But there's something,
you know that really does connect us,
handwriting it's like we go to restaurants and the food,
well, you know, before COVID we used to go to restaurants
and if we were on a big, long kind of family you know,
friends dinner, it could be 20 people, 24 people,
we always like to mix each other,
you know, we never like to sit next to each other
when we go for dinner parties,
we do want to talk to other people
and so if Michael's down the other table,
down one end and I'm down the other,
you can guarantee we're ordering the same
appetizer, main course and dessert.
It sounds like made for each other.
(upbeat music)